oh
oh what is this
a a meatball
really it's always more fun to mess with
Dwight with an audience that was usually
Pam so now that she's out I had to find
someone
else turns out that Stanley is quite the
comedy
fan but not everything makes him
laugh he has very specific
tastes
through a painstaking process of trial
and error I found out what he
likes and it's really weird Jim come on
SO
juvenile what the you've been
meatballed are you ready for some
meatball oh
man this is not very clever Jim I know
look for your
stapler really Jim
really very
funny okay
good what's the hall 32 meatballs good
day that idiot's been feeding us for a
week we'll never have to buy meatballs
again
[Music]
it's a miracle she loves
him I don't know about love she loves
me outside my car 2
minutes all right something's come up I
got to go no no no she'll wake up no I
have something to do I know what you
have to do please stay with
CeCe twight I've always considered us to
be very good friends great friends
remember your concussion I do but you
married my worst enemy I know well I
think enemies is strong word cuz I think
we have a really Charming back and
forth I will require beer and pizza to
think this over absolutely from Jim well
I don't think that's going to
happen what kind of pizza would you
like surprise me no
pepperoni insert it in my mouth okay
that's not going to make your pizza
eating experience any better trust me oh
try me Jim just don't think of it as
degrading think of it as you happen to
be moving the pizza six in this way and
he happens to be biting it i' prefer for
him to think of it as degrading
okay crust
first okay now the
beer beer me
J
gentle we can get him to drive to get
out rock side in his air what the hell
is this what are you trying to cop a
feel or something dude no dude no dude I
was just Listen whoa God I don't even I
don't even know how to explain this um
uh Dwight asked me to be in an
alliance and then um um we were we've
just been messing with him uh because of
the whole Alliance thing um it's just
office pranks it's stupid it's just
office pranks and Alliance what the hell
is he talking
about I have absolutely no
idea come
on do I feel bad about betraying Jim not
at all that's the game convince him
we're in an alliance get some
information throw him to the Wolves
that's politics baby get what you can
out of someone then crush them I think
Jim might have learned a very valuable
lesson uh yeah I just got my replacement
credit
card do you want the number oh it's uh
3313 this security code is
927 okay great thank you very much
bye so Dwight did take the
bait he used my credit card numbers to
send a $200 bouquet of
flowers to my
wife from
[Laughter]
me boom hey Jimmy what's up not much
cool very cool I bet if you tried you
could grow the best beard of anyone in
this office thanks toy that laugh is so
infectious creeping me out I'm going to
go I didn't mean any of those things I
just said and you can expect the same
thing from everyone in this office if
you don't nip this whole Employee of the
Month situation in the bud make it about
the work I guess you think you should
get it this encompass is all available
data hours tardiness unconfirmed sick
days participation everyone has been
assigned a random number for total
fairness and transparency also this
should be accompanied by a monetary
prize Well in an Ideal World in an Ideal
World I would have all 10 fingers on my
left hand so my right hand could just be
a fist for punching okay if it's all the
same to you I'm just going to take away
survival skills and self-defense I'm
going to run this by Toby and accouny
and have him assemble the data that's
okay I'll do it
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome I know
you're all very excited but no matter
who gets this I just want to say that
you guys are all employees of the month
in my
eyes and the winner is employee number
nine and that is number nine number nine
Jim Halbert what are you kidding oh no
okay wait I was not
I did not I did not that was not how
come not listen this was Anonymous all
right there's no way I could have given
it to myself because I didn't even know
who was on here I just gave it to the
employee with the highest overall score
to my Tally you just won back your own
parking spot a vacation day and a nice
tidy quarter of $1,000 from all of us
well everybody just stop for a second
cuz obviously I'm not taking any of it a
mistake has been made and we'll figure
it out second of all there was no cash
PR
yes Dwight yeah you said in an Ideal
World there would be a cash prize isn't
that what you said no Dwight I meant yes
in a perfect world someone would get
money but not but in your perfect world
only you get money yeah that's don't I
know all right David Wallace's office
this is Kevin Malone is David there no
he's on his weekly Staffing you can I
take a message tell him I'm mad at Jim
cuz he's asking us to give money to pay
this is Stanley Hudson Jim Halbert is a
menace it's Toby
Fenderson listen things are getting
really bad down
here you've reached the voicemail of
Dwight Kurt shut please
leave
[Music]
stop I have no feeling in my fingers or
penis but I think it was worth
it um I was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept throwing
him until he exhausted himself and uh
then how about icing it LOL
Dwight hey pickles Merry Christmas open
immediately love swiss
cheese damn it Dwight didn't think your
affectionate nicknames would be your
undoing did you Jim let that be a lesson
to you all
I'm
sorry I had no idea no it's it's
okay okay oh my God oh my God no no no
no
okay this is it what this is what oh my
God
honey
J in the end the greatest snowball isn't
a snowball at all it's fear
Merry
Christmas